bonsoir et bienvenue sur LCP pour cette
soirée autour des 1 an de la guerre en
Ukraine la justice peut-elle passer dans
un pays en guerre c'est la question que
l'on va se poser ce soir avec mes
invités dont les deux réalisatrices
marine Courtade et Ilona Schulz qui ont
réalisé ce document inédit vous allez
découvrir tout de suite comment enquêter
quand l'urgence c'est la survie comment
rendre justice à des victimes murées
dans le silence crime sexuel de guerre
documenté l'horreur document inédit pour
LCP donc regardez
[Musique]
Galina a osé parler à visage découvert
parce qu'elle n'est plus si jeune parce
qu'elle n'a peut-être plus rien à perdre
et surtout au nom de tous les autres
[Musique]
car depuis le début de l'invasion russe
de nombreux cadeaux violences sexuelles
sont rapportés des femmes des hommes des
enfants
[Musique]
combien sont-ils impossible de donner
une estimation
[Musique]
ici à Kiev au bureau du procureur
général les dossiers arrivent au
compte-goutte
[Musique]
8 procureurs sont chargés depuis le mois
de septembre d'enquêter exclusivement
sur les crimes sexuels commis dans cette
guerre
une première dans un conflit en cours
mais pour l'instant
155 dossiers seulement sont instruits
dans le fracas des bombes
l'urgence n'est pas à la parole
la priorité des gens c'est de survivre
j'espère que dans le futur les gens
parleront plus facilement pour l'instant
ils ont surtout peur que les occupants
reviennent
comment enquêter lorsque le quotidien
des habitants est rythmé par les combats
comment repérer les victimes réduites au
silence sous le poids de la honte
et comment leur rendre justice
[Musique]
je vais mettre mon sac sous le vôtre oui
pas de souci la règle numéro 1 pour les
procureurs c'est désormais de quitter
leur bureau et de privilégier le terrain
à tour de rôle il sillonne les zones de
guerre en quête de témoignages
ce matin c'est au tour d'Olga
une longue route pour se rendre à isum
une ville occupée par les Russes pendant
presque 6 mois
si tu es dans la région de carquif à
l'est du pays elle est aujourd'hui à 70
km du front
la région de kerki fait bombarder
presque tous les jours je n'ai pas peur
nos vies dépendent de la volonté divine
chacun sa destinée et moi c'est ma
responsabilité et mon travail d'aller
aider les gens
j'en tire une certaine fierté
pour vous de venir ici
les gens se méfient des autorités
judiciaires alors nous venons au contact
des victimes pour qu'il ne nous
craignent pas pour qu'il n'ait pas peur
de témoigner
les témoignages sont très importants
pour notre travail
la ville porte les stigmates des combats
les rues sont fuis il y a seulement 5
mois un passé à vif Colga va tenter de
sonder
sa mission commence dans le bureau du
maire
[Musique]
je suis procureur ma fonction c'est
d'enquêter sur les violences sexuelles
commises au cours de cette guerre
pour vous vous êtes peut-être déjà au
courant mais ici on a déjà recensé
beaucoup de cas de violence sexuelles
sur les femmes
voici Nadia directrice du service social
de la ville d'izum avec Nadia patriar on
prend toutes ces histoires très à coeur
ce n'est pas possible de faire autrement
vous avez plus de contacts que nous avec
les habitants les gens vous parlent plus
facilement qu'à nous si vous entendez
parler d'un cas qui concerne notre
domaine faites-nous signe et on viendra
votre numéro de téléphone oui bien sûr
je vais vous l'écrire
les gens vont-ils se confier à un
procureur qu'il ne connaissent pas
olgave rassuré
a besoin de temps avant de parler quand
elle se sentira vraiment prête alors à
ce moment-là nous reviendrons la voir et
nous irons au fond des choses avec elle
merci au revoir
[Musique]
pour se faire connaître les procureurs
ont fait imprimer des brochures
d'information
et le meilleur endroit pour trouver du
monde c'est au point d'aide humanitaire
notre caméra reste en retrait
bureau du procureur général désolé de
vous déranger pour les femmes qui ont
été victimes de violences sexuelles
voilà des brochures vous y trouverez
toutes les informations pour obtenir de
l'aide et là il y a un numéro d'urgence
dans les brochures roses bonjour bureau
du procureur général
Holga en profite pour poser des
questions au hasard des rencontres
de civil
non nous sommes restés tout le temps
chez nous ça tirait de partout les
bombes voler au-dessus de nos têtes
Olga le sait ce sont les femmes qui
parleront plus facilement
les hommes eux sont plus fermés même
s'ils ont été victimes de violence
sexuelles il ne le diront jamais comme
ça dans la rue à une étrangère
[Musique]
ce jour là Olga ne recueillera ni
information ni indice mais à la semé des
graines elle reviendra ici si des
victimes se décident à parler et à se
faire aider
de temps que représentant judiciaire
notre but bien sûr c'est que la victime
obtienne toute l'aide psychologique et
morale nécessaire il faut aussi que les
criminels soient punis que la victime
puisse avoir la satisfaction de savoir
que son bourreau a été puni en
distribuant ses brochures on veut aussi
montrer aux gens que la société ne les a
pas abandonnés
ne pas abandonner les victimes c'est
l'objectif de cette unité spéciale
des victimes qui se sont trop longtemps
et trop souvent senti livrés à
elles-mêmes
dans l'ouest de l'Ukraine à Poliana loin
des zones de combat
Galina celle qui a porté plainte vient
de parcourir 700 km pour retrouver les
femmes de l'association Sénat
le viol qu'elle a subi elle leur a déjà
raconté aujourd'hui elle est venue
parler de la suite quand son village a
été libéré elle a demandé une aide
médicale pour ses douleurs au ventre
mauvaise surprise au cabinet du médecin
ce sont des hommes du SBU les services
de renseignement Ukrainiens qui se sont
occupés d'elle
un de ces hommes m'a dit de me
déshabiller pendant que la gynécologue
restait loin dans un coin de la pièce
quand j'ai écarté les jambes il a dit ah
oui le cas est très clair là
et l'autre a fait des photos
la docteur a tout vu mais elle n'a pas
bougé
je lui ai dit j'ai besoin d'un
traitement j'ai demandé tous les tests
possibles pour le sida les maladies
sexuellement transmissibles il m'avait
fait ça dans de telles conditions
la gynécologue m'a dit qu'elle ne
pouvait pas le faire à moins que je paye
du coup j'ai emprunté de l'argent à mon
voisin
merci beaucoup d'avoir partagé ton
histoire avec nous tu mets en évidence
un vrai problème
comment le gouvernement a pu
m'abandonner comme ça
à partir de maintenant tout va aller
mieux
oui ça va
j'ai passé tellement de temps toute
seule et maintenant je suis très
contente de vous avoir les filles
toutes ces femmes qui la soutiennent ont
elles aussi subi des violences sexuelles
quelques années avant gallina dès 2014
dans la région du Dombas elles ont
ensuite créé cette association pour
s'épauler
8 ans après elles ont enfin le sentiment
que les choses commencent un peu à
bouger
ouvertement
et personne ne comprenait vraiment notre
souffrance
a commencé j'ai l'impression que le
monde entier et les autorités
ukrainiennes commencent enfin à nous
croire à croire ce qui nous est arrivé
avec ce qu'elle a vécu Irina est
persuadée qu'elle trouvera les mots pour
libérer la parole mieux qu'un procureur
ou qu'un policier
alors depuis le printemps elle se rend
dans les territoires libérés en quête de
témoignage
accompagné de son mari elle prend
aujourd'hui la direction de Kerson une
ville située en pleine zone de guerre
sur la ligne de front au sud du pays
ah tiens il y a une station-service là
elle est complètement détruite
c'est comme quand on est allé à bout de
chat
Irina et son mari n'arrive pas à les
mains vides
puisqu'il est si difficile d'obtenir des
tests eux vont les mettre à disposition
des victimes
comme c'est absolument nécessaire pour
les femmes aujourd'hui
ils
restera les femmes thèse leur viol par
peur du retour des militaires russes
Ronin
elle ne s'adresse même pas un médecin
qui est dramatique si jamais elles ont
été infectées
son combat est une revanche sur son
histoire personnelle
je suis bien viol avec un sac sur la
tête
et
après
je ne pourrais jamais
identifier ce type
ne sera jamais puni s'il est encore
vivant et moi je
rêve mondiale
avec le temps Irina s'est constituée un
réseau d'informateurs on lui a parlé
d'une femme qui pourrait connaître des
victimes
bonjour
il est mignon ce petit bout de chou tout
en bleu
elle vit ici avec son mari et un
orphelin de guerre qu'ils ont adopté
je viens vous voir vous parce que vous
circulez dans la région que vous parlez
avec les gens du coin vous avez
certainement des contacts vous avez dû
entendre des choses je voudrais vous
demander oui je comprends il s'est passé
plein de choses dans le coin moi
ces personnes là on doit les aider
la conversation prend alors une tournure
inattendue
ça m'est arrivé à moi
mon mari ne veut pas que je le raconte
mais
on a été dénoncé on a été dénoncé pour
avoir aidé l'armée ukrainienne
lorsqu'ils sont arrivés j'ai passé deux
jours dans leur sous-sol au début ils
m'ont électrocuté avec un truc comme ça
je n'ai pas pu bien voir parce que ma
tête était couverte puis je suis tombée
dans les pommes ils m'ont violé à
plusieurs reprises ils ont fini par me
libérer et là ils ont même voulu m'aider
oui pour se déculpabiliser c'est ça
c'est mon histoire Irina découvre
qu'elle a en face d'elle une victime
elle connaît la procédure mais dites moi
vous en avez parlé au procureur sans que
votre mari ne soit au courant donc
seulement au SBO seulement au service de
renseignement c'est bien mais c'est le
bureau du procureur qui collecte les
témoignages c'est lui remonte les
dossiers
en fait je ne suis pas allé voir le
procureur parce que vous savez mon mari
souffre beaucoup de ne pas avoir pu me
protéger c'est aussi pour ça que je ne
voulais pas qu'il assiste à cette
conversation
regardez ça c'est pour vous de ma part
je vais vous laisser aussi ces boîtes
même si la date d'expiration approche ce
sont des autôtesses ces tests
[Musique]
Irina reviendra le lendemain elle veut
persuader la victime de parler au
procureur
convaincre les femmes de porter plainte
ne suffit pas il faut accumuler les
indices les preuves lors des conflits
passés trop de violences sexuelles sont
restées impunies faute d'enquête
immédiate
dans les locaux en état de siège du
bureau du procureur de Kiev une course
contre la montre s'engage
la chef de l'unité spéciale Irina
didenko doit avec ses équipes aller vite
ne rien laisser au
[Musique]
hasarder des éléments différents dans
certains cas on a pu saisir les papiers
les documents sur place on peut aussi
retrouver les traces d'ADN on a même
mené des examens médicaux légaux qui ont
confirmé ces faits de violence sexuelles
on tente de récupérer un maximum de
preuves et pour ça il y a tout un
protocole à suivre on essaie aussi de
comprendre comment ces criminels de
guerre se sont déplacés où ils sont
allés s'ils ont commis des crimes dans
plusieurs maisons parce qu'il arrive
souvent qu'il passe de maison en maison
à la recherche de femmes
enquêter pour nourrir de futurs procès
et peut-être envisager un jour la
création d'un tribunal spécial
pour cela dossier après dossier les
procureurs tentent de remonter la chaîne
des responsabilités un travail difficile
[Musique]
pour s'orienter dans les subtilités du
droit il y a a pris un avocat
il a 22 ans et en avril dernier il a été
violé un check pour une par des soldats
russes
depuis ce traumatisme il a tenté de se
suicider à plusieurs reprises
[Musique]
quel était son grade a-t-il donné ou
reçu des ordres
de la réponse à ces questions dépend
toute la procédure judiciaire lancée par
son avocat
s
ils pourront être traduits à la haine
devant la justice internationale
et les autres ceux qui ont obéi à cet
ordre iront devant les tribunaux
Ukrainiens
il est possible que certains d'entre eux
soient aujourd'hui dans nos prisons
c'est pour ça qu'on doit travailler
ensemble pour
identifier ces gens aussi vite que
possible
je suis sûr que la Cour pénale
internationale de la haine restera pas
silencieuse
il n'y a pas de délai de prescription
pour ces cas
non il n'y a pas de délai même s'il est
coupable sont identifiés et retrouvés
dans très longtemps même dans 10 ans ce
que je ne souhaite pas il ne pourront
pas échapper à leur responsabilité
car c'est un crime de guerre
et un crime de guerre n'a pas de date de
prescription c'est bon à entendre
l'avocat d'Ilia a lancé une double
procédure auprès du procureur de Kiev et
devant la Cour pénale internationale
en Ukraine la CPI a ouvert une enquête
en mars dernier crime de guerre crimes
contre l'humanité génocide c'est elle
qui déterminera la qualification des
crimes sexuels
tout le monde est prêt
et aider à qualifier ses crimes Anna et
son équipe d'experts internationaux se
sont installés à Kiev ils seconde les
procureurs dans leurs enquêtes
avec eux ils cherchent à prouver le côté
systématique de ces viols
je travaille en ce moment sur un cas de
violence sexuelle commise sur une femme
dans la région de Kiev dans un village
qui a été occupé
et pour moi il y a un point intéressant
l'auteur présumait appartiendrait à la
même unité qu'un des types de ton
dossier de Nice je pense qu'il faut le
signaler au procureur il y a des
éléments de systématisme
d'ailleurs les soldats russes quand ils
occupaient ce village il cherchait des
signes d'appartenance à la nation
ukrainienne
pourraient indiquer une certaine
intention
ça pourrait bien confirmer cette théorie
que nous sommes dans un crime
systématique et pas dans des incidents
aléatoires
155 dossiers c'est encore trop peu pour
vraiment identifier et confirmer des
éléments de systématisme mais quand on
regarde la situation région par région
on commence à voir que dans certaines
zones il y a le même type de pratique
criminelles qui se répètent et comment
certains cas sont très similaires
c'est violent sexuel font-elles partie
d'une stratégie sont-elles utilisées
comme une arme de guerre
pour l'avocat il y a forcément une
responsabilité des autorités russes
[Musique]
je suis persuadé qu'il n'y a pas d'ordre
écrit qui dirait violer les citoyens du
crayon
ce serait ridicule mais en fait c'est en
eux dans leur tête
et les autorités au plus haut niveau
n'ont fait que mettre de l'huile sur le
feu en disant que l'Ukraine n'est pas un
état et qu'ici il y a des mauvaises
personnes qui ne méritent pas de voir
leurs droits respectés
malheureusement sur l'intégralité du
territoire ukrainien un schéma se
dessine partout ou des militaires russes
étaient présents il y a eu des crimes à
caractère sexuel
personne n'est protégée ni les femmes ni
les hommes ni les enfants cela touche
tous les civils de 4 à 82 ans
pour nous c'est crimes sexuels ne sont
pas des cas isolés c'est une manœuvre
systématique d'intimidation et
d'extermination de la population locale
en Ukraine trois procès ont déjà eu lieu
seulement par contre humains
pour rendre justice aux victimes
procureur experts et associations vont
continuer leur long travail d'enquête
voilà donc pour ce document inédit LCP
que vous avez réalisé marine Courtat
bonsoir et bonsoir il en est chaude on
va revenir largement sur la manière dont
vous avez pu suivre cette procureur
aciev sur la manière dont vous avez
recueilli ces témoignages bonsoir Céline
Bardet ravi de vous accueillir vous êtes
juriste international spécialisé sur les
crimes de guerre sur les crimes
internationaux vous êtes la fondatrice
de l'ONG we are notens of War sur les
crimes sexuels dans les conflits bonsoir
Véronique naomgrap et bienvenue
anthropologue et ethnologue vous avez
beaucoup travaillé sur ces questions de
crime sexuels Mariana Perret bene Sike
est restée avec nous bonsoir rebonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes journaliste
ukrainienne indépendante alors je me
tourne d'abord vers vous deux Ilona
Schulz c'est rare je le disais
d'entendre des témoignages comme comme
cela
c'est c'est difficile de porter plainte
évidemment dans un pays en guerre c'est
aussi très difficile d'accepter une
caméra vous avez déjà travaillé je crois
sur ces questions de crime sexuelle
comment on arrive à confondre ces femmes
cet homme qui témoigne non seulement de
le faire mais avec le regard d'une
caméra
déjà je crois que effectivement le fait
que on ait travaillé marin et moi en
Ukraine depuis longtemps et notamment si
sur les crimes sexuels depuis 2016
on a noué des contacts forcément à des
interlocuteurs sur place
voilà qui facilite les choses et puis et
la connaissance de ce sujet de ce sujet
là c'est la justice
ukrainienne et notamment cette procureur
qui vous a amené assez ces femmes là pas
forcément à ces personnes là mais de
manière générale que ce soit au niveau
des associations des avocats qui
travaillent sur ce sujet depuis
longtemps parce que comme on l'a vu
c'est des crimes des homosexuel ne date
pas que de l'invasion à grande échelle
donc il y a déjà ça et puis
après c'est aussi une une posture en
fait à avoir je pense quand on rencontre
ces personnes là ne jamais enfin faire
comprendre que on n'est pas là pour les
forcer à obtenir absolument un
témoignage on est là pour raconter
l'histoire qui veulent bien nous nous
confier dans une posture respectueuse et
sans jamais
forcer le questionnement il y a une
écoute et un regard particulier on le
voit bien dans dans le film marine
Courtade il y a cette scène incroyable
ou Irina cette femme ukrainienne qui a
été victime d'un viol avant cette guerre
là
sillonne le pays avec son association et
réalise à la faveur d'une conversation
avec une femme dans un village qu'elle a
en face d'elle une victime une victime
de viol cette scène là par exemple
vous saviez ce qui allait se passer en
la tournant non alors ça ça a été une
vraie surprise pour le coup parce que
nous on partait avec Irina dans ce
village là en pensant qu'on allait
rencontrer une témoin qui allait
peut-être nous amener vers d'autres
victimes et qui allait nous raconter ce
qui s'était passé dans ce village là et
tout d'un coup elle se met à raconter
elle éloigne son mari nous en plus on
parle pas la langue ou on travaille dans
ce pays depuis longtemps mais on n'a pas
appris cette langue et donc on filme la
scène d'Irina avec cette femme et puis
on a notre traductrice avec nous qui
tout d'un coup nous dit ah mais là je
crois qu'il se passe quelque chose et
donc nous à ce moment-là on se demande
aussi qu'est-ce qu'on fait nous en tant
que journaliste alors que la caméra est
déjà
enclenché filmé et donc du coup on
laisse les choses se passer et puis
après on a discuté avec cette femme et
on a voilà un peu expliqué ce qu'on
faisait pourquoi on était là et discuter
aussi de son de la question de son
anonymat parce que c'était une vraie
question qui se posait
qui se pose d'ailleurs pour toutes les
victimes qu'on a rencontrées je précise
que les lieux ne sont pas nommés un deux
dans le film et que évidemment elles ont
donné leur accord et c'est leur volonté
de témoigner à visage découvert encore
une question et puis je fais circuler la
parole ce qui se dégage du film c'est à
la fois que c'est assez précurseur c'est
assez fort de voir une justice
en acte dans un état en guerre et en
même temps elle a un côté tellement
artisanal et tellement fragile est-ce
que c'est l'état d'esprit des procureurs
des magistrats ils sont conscients de ça
eux ils sont extrêmement motivés de de
faire avancer la justice de faire
avancer les enquêtes etc cette unité
spéciale elle a été créée en septembre
et en fait depuis qu'ils ont créé cette
unité ils ont vu aussi les limites dans
les dans lesquelles ils se sont
retrouvés notamment sur la question la
protection des victimes et ça c'est des
choses sur lesquelles ils ont avancé
petit à petit ils ont modifié ils ne
cessent en fait de modifier
fonctionnement en fonction des retours
des victimes en fonction de ce qui se
passe aussi sur place parce que la ligne
de front ne cesse de bouger et tout
bouge donc en fait voilà ils sont dans
une adaptation permanente avec les
limites que comporte d'enquêter dans un
pays qui est dans le conflit continu
c'est une Bardet comment vous vous
réagissez à ce film évidemment des
témoignages vous vous en avez recueilli
entendu
au fond il y a cette dimension
incroyable d'une d'une justice en acte
en temps de guerre est-ce qu'elle elle
va trop vite est-ce que ça vous inquiète
ou est-ce que ça vous réjouit
non j'ai envie de dire ni l'un ni
l'autre c'est à dire que enfin c'est
quand même ça m'inquiète si un peu et
puis après il y a quelque chose qu'il
faut comprendre c'est qu'il y a deux il
y a deux étapes il y a la question de la
documentation d'aller recueillir des
témoignages c'est à dire collecter les
éléments de preuve et le processus de
justice qui déjà sont deux choses
différentes et en effet l'Ukraine a mis
en place un processus de justice au
niveau national qui est un peu ralenti
là c'est inédit alors ça c'est payant
c'est totalement inédit surtout surtout
à un niveau national et ça a posé
beaucoup de questions parce que je pense
que ces procès n'ont pas été même avec
la meilleure volonté qui soit parce
qu'il y a une volonté laissée procès là
n'ont pas été menées je pense dans les
standards dans lesquels ils auraient dû
être menés donc mais c'est très
compliqué en fait de faire ça en plein
voilà en plein conflit et puis l'autre
question parce que est-ce que le fait de
le faire en plein conflit on voit bien
qu'il y a une question de justice il y a
une question politique aussi on va en
parler mais
le principal le message l'impunité pour
les crimes de guerre c'est fini c'est ça
que ça renvoie aussi comme comme message
oui à dire que c'est maintenant qu'ils
sont commis les crimes et donc c'est
maintenant qu'il faut avoir les preuves
oui Non Non mais encore une fois avoir
les preuves c'est une chose mais ça ça a
été le positionnement des élanski c'est
un ski il a dit ah on va se défendre on
va résister et deux on répondra avec le
droit donc oui c'est ce qu'ils font
maintenant il n'empêche que il faut
avoir des des auteurs de crimes donc il
faut les arrêter il faut qu'il soit sur
le territoire et on voit que c'est pas
toujours le cas et ensuite il faut
respecter un minimum de standard aussi
parce que son écrit complexes à
poursuivre donc c'est pour ça que c'est
important la justice elle a besoin de
temps que ça nous plaise ou non la
justice elle a besoin de temps on va y
revenir à cette question centrale du
temps Véronique naomgrap comment vous
vous réagissez à ce film il y a un
travail de réparation aussi qui est à
l'oeuvre avec ses premiers témoignages
on est au-delà peut-être même de la
question de la justice parce que je
trouve formidable c'est quand une des
personnes dit je veux que ça n'arrive
plus jamais sur la planète entière
c'est-à-dire que oui la justice est
fragile oui elle est lente oui peut-être
on sera tous mort avant que le premier
criminel soit traîné derrière les
barreaux mais le rêve de justice était
énorme le plus jamais ça nous on le
traîne depuis tout le temps je crois
tout mais depuis 45 donc au moins au
moins mais je crois qu'après chaque
crime infâme il y a cette idée plus
jamais ça et sur la planète entière donc
il y a cette question du rêve de justice
et qui est impossible à effacer de la
même aussi important que la justice
elle-même exactement
l'autre chose aussi qui a été terrible
avec ses crimes donc toute torture est
un viol tout viol est une torture dans
ces conditions et donc tout viole est
une torture dans toutes les conditions
donc si vous voulez il faut donner le
mot la dignité du mot torture et ce qui
a particulier c'est que contrairement
aux crimes non sexuel sexuelle ont des
un effet de soudure qui salit
immédiatement la victime même une
victime qui n'est pas dans une idée très
traditionnelle dans les dans les
sociétés très traditionnelles où la
définition de la femme son honneur tient
sa sexualité elle est foutue tout
l'Ancien Régime les viols sont suivis de
punitions et d'infamides d'infamie
sociale de la femme violée ou la très
jeune fille violée et même encore les
crimes d'honneur peuvent un père peut
tuer sa fille de 16 ans parce qu'elle a
été violée et c'est elle qui porte la
souillure sur l'ensemble de la famille
mais il n'y a pas que ça même dans les
sociétés très évoluées et on voit la
dame qui dit je le fais parce que je
suis un peu âgé je le fais pour parler
parce que moi je parle il y a une honte
c'est-à-dire ce sont des crimes les
crimes de soudure font basculer la
salissure dans le corps même de la
victime et cette honte est une des
choses qui portent vraiment qui empêche
et qui qui empêche pour ces crimes
infernaux que le travail classique de la
comme dans les romans policiers puissent
être fait normalement Mariana Perret la
messieurs le déclencheur de la volonté
des Hélène ski de faire travailler la
justice et le plus vite possible ces
bouts de chat ces bouts de chats et les
et les possibles charniers qu'on a
découvert la frontière russe à partir de
là les ukrainiens et le pouvoir
ukrainien a décidé que il fallait mettre
le paquet sur la justice même si on le
voit c'est très fragile mais il y a
quand même plusieurs procureurs et des
et des cas qui sont qui sont regardés il
y a plusieurs aspects à cela et je pense
que les auteurs de ce formidable
documentaire que nous a frappé toute et
j'espère tous les spectateurs aussi
peuvent en témoigner aussi il y a
plusieurs raisons à cela premièrement
l'Ukraine contrairement à ce qu'on peut
penser l'Ukraine reste un état
fonctionnel l'Ukraine a été l'état
fonctionnel tout au long dès les
premiers jours de l'invasion ce qui est
un exploit en soi décidément on en a
déjà bien parlé surtout madame
c'est que
la justice est un aspect extrêmement
important il ne s'agit pas que de
récupérer les territoires par exemple
d'avoir il y a aussi toute cette
dimension là
c'est une manière de répondre à
l'arbitraire de la barbarie de la
violence les Ukrainiens veulent répondre
par la justice exactement les messages
par ailleurs on peut voir ça aussi dans
la société ukrainienne les Ukrainiens ne
sont pas pour une sorte d'élanchage ou
pour des venaient à les Ukrainiens sont
pour la justice en elle-même par contre
là où je ne serai probablement pas
d'accord c'est que la justice est-ce
qu'elle est plus rapide ou plus longue
que d'habitude à ce que je constate moi
par rapport à ma connaissance au rythme
de travail de la justice ukrainienne je
suis
étonné de voir qu'en fait elle suit plus
ou moins son rythme normal plus ou moins
et ça c'est
l'officier russe Vadim a été jugé et ça
a été le premier
officier russe qui a tiré sur un
cycliste c'est très médiatique mais pour
une affaire aussi simple avec des
témoins et avec des preuves il y en
ayant un coupable c'était quoi c'était
un mois et demi de moi ça ça peut être
très rapide en effet à l'Ukraine mais
après une Bardet d'accord avec ça non je
suis pas je suis pas complètement
d'accord non chichi marine c'est chichi
marine effectivement c'est une affaire
simple
mais la question aussi c'est par exemple
ici on parle de crime internationaux
donc c'est ça aussi et l'intérêt aussi
c'est de voir si on peut remonter des
unités etc à l'histoire de chichi marine
moi ce qui d'abord il a été condamné à
perpétuité en première instance ensuite
ça a été changé alors il faut rappeler
un tout petit peu des faits donc c'est
officiers russes qui fuyant dans une
voiture
un cycliste civil et ça c'est
constitutif de crimes de guerre de tirer
sur un civil en conflit donc voilà je
suis d'accord que l'effet était assez
simple il les a reconnu etc très bien ça
a été jugé quand même en trois jours je
crois maintenant la question elle aurait
été intéressante de savoir quel est le
contexte de ça il y avait d'autres
personnes avec lui dans la voiture et
tout je dis pas ça pour le discréditer
lui mais où le décharger de sa
responsabilité mais c'est ça et et en
plus il y a eu la question de la peine
et je suis d'accord que au moins il y a
une vraie démarche d'aller dans la
justice et moi c'est ça je trouve
extrêmement moi je suis très admiratif
de l'Ukraine et comme vous le rappelez
aussi c'est vrai que c'est un état qui
reste fonctionnel alors malgré la
situation reprenons un tout petit peu
les termes et on va revenir au crime
sexuel mais crime de guerre pour que les
gens comprennent bien un crime de guerre
là on est dans une ampleur inédite
depuis il faut remonter à quoi la guerre
en Yougoslavie pour retrouver ce cette
ampleur là crime de guerre c'est quoi
c'est tout crimes qui est commis à
l'encontre d'un civil ou d'ailleurs ça
peut être aussi un mauvais traitement
d'un d'un prisonnier combattant toutes
ces formes là sur un terrain de conflit
quand on a un conflit ça constitue des
criminaires et les crimes contre
l'humanité les crimes génocidaires
supposent une intention politique
d'exterminer la population en partie ou
en totalité ou pas complètement mais de
l'exterminer dans son identité
collective c'est-à-dire dans son passé
qu'elle n'est plus de passer dans son
avenir or les viols entendent guerre où
il y a beaucoup de témoignages qui
montrent que le les acteurs disent tu
n'auras plus d'enfants ukrainiens et qui
sont d'ailleurs en lien avec cette idée
qu'on enlève aussi le passé le tyran
adore être présent pour l'éternité
jadis et à jamais et donc il aborde les
cimetières il brûle les livres d'écoles
d'historiens il change l'histoire et sa
façon d'envahir l'avenir imaginairement
l'arbre de filiation des des de la
communauté qu'il veut anéantir dont il
veut anéantir le la présence même s'il
ne tue pas tout le monde sait faire
l'enfant de l'ennemi c'est envahir
l'arbre de filiation c'est faire
l'enfant de l'ennemi à la femme pour
envahir l'avenir elle aura elle sera
rucifiée elle aura un russe elle est
mais c'est en même temps c'est
entièrement fou c'est une croyance et
pour les anthropologues le fils n'érite
pas des qualités morales du père il y a
pas voilà et la fille de la mère on voit
bien qu'il y a une dissymétrie il y a un
problème avec cette croyance dans la
question du crime sexuel en temps de
guerre la question c'est c'est on
comprend la dimension la signification
symbolique à laquelle vous vous référez
mais c'est la question l'intention et
c'est la question de l'ordre aussi alors
juste que je veux dire c'est que le mot
génocide qui a une définition très
sérieuse pour les juristes si on le
traduit c'est gainos naissance donc
l'assassinat de la naissance il me
semble que cette définition littérale
sans ambition modeste en quelque sorte
mais littéral peut être réfléchie aussi
au plan juridique c'est à dire que des
crimes les viols massifs jamais puni
encourager en aura jamais les ordres
mais si on décore le bataillon qui a été
à bout de chasse et bien que on
reconnaît que les crimes étaient que
tous ces crimes sont licites et sont
presque applaudis et sont applaudis et
donc ça veut bien dire qu'il y a une
dimension avec ses violentes de guerre
de tentatives d'anéantir le l'avenir
imaginaire de la collectivité au travers
de la section donc l'anthropologue que
vous êtes ne dit pas comme on entend
beaucoup attention
génocide on verra qu'après si c'est
vraiment un génocide c'est trop tôt non
moi au contraire on est à un an de
guerre on a toute une série de
témoignages moi je suis la notion de
génocide a été inventée à cause de
l'exceptionnalité des crimes des nazis
il y a de l'exceptionnalité il faut être
souple il faut pas le considérer que
l'insurgent génocide d'une vache sacrée
à laquelle plus personne ne doit toucher
et donc ça protégerait tous les
génocides qu'on n'aurait pas le droit
d'appeler génocide pour 21e siècle merci
Claire de nous protéger les futurs
génocidaires et donc moi je suis pour
qu'on utilise c'est un outil c'est un
outil efficace et je pense que dans ce
cas là l'idée d'anéantir la nation
ukrainienne en tant qu'ukrainienne dans
lever les enfants de mettre des
passeports russes de les russifier c'est
une dimension
génocidaire non pas physique non pas là
bien sûr pas comme Hitler etc mais au
moins comment dire politique de le mot
symbolique ne serait pas adéquat mais en
tant que nationalité c'est anéantir un
identique collective anéantir une nation
toute entière en tant que nation et on
pourrait dire les femmes pour les crimes
sexuels les souliers même les hommes les
réduire au silence la question
maintenant on entend on entend
l'anthropologue mais c'est comment on
poursuit ça et sur quel fondement est-ce
que est-ce que un tribunal pénal
international spécifique est-ce que il y
a moyen de montrer de prouver que ça
fait partie d'une forme de chaîne de
commandement d'une atmosphère je vous
fais réagir mais on a retrouvé vous
savez les mots de Vladimir Poutine juste
avant l'entrée en guerre le fameux ma
jolie ça c'est quelque chose qui est
très impressionnant quand même ces mots
issus d'une chanson du folklore russe
adresse
qui on va les retrouver et lui dit en
gros ma jolie faudra supporter que ça te
plaise ou non voilà 7 février 2022 quand
on dit ça avec cette violence là est-ce
que c'est pas une forme d'autorisation
à l'horreur dans la chanson originale ça
s'adresse à une femme décédée dans son
cercueil
il en est Schulz est-ce qu'il y a au
fond une forme de de continuum entre le
chef du Kremlin quelque chose qui dans
les mots dans l'atmosphère on voit la
barbarie de ces soldats qu'on sort de
prison qui ont sont des assassins et le
terrain
pour l'instant ce qui ce qui commence à
émerger récemment en tout cas dans les
mots des procureurs sur place c'est que
il commence à parler de d'implication du
commandement notamment dans les crimes
sexuels dans les experts aussi qui sont
sur place commencent à parler d'un
faisceau d'indices sur le fait que dans
une trentaine de dossiers il y aurait
des signes de consentement du
commandement donc ça c'est des éléments
voilà les procureurs cite aussi par
exemple le fait qu'on ait retrouvé des
préservatifs que des soldats russes
revenus avec des préservatifs qui est la
torture sexuelle en détention avec la
torture sur les sur les sur les enfin
voilà sur les par électrocus sur les
organes génitaux pardon mais en revanche
c'est encore pour les experts qu'on a
suivi sur place c'est encore trop tôt
beaucoup trop tôt les enquêtes en sont
instad initial il y a pas encore de
preuves d'un plan préconçu etc il y a
une culture du viol il y a une
de la du bizutage où les jeunes gens
sont violés dans une grande violence
avec des morts et donc cette culture du
viol qui est étudiée qui est cette
imprimation entre la culture du KGB et
la culture des truand mais déjà ça génie
sinon passé la politique le monde
politique le discours politique rue de
du Kremlin de avec le pouvoir poutinien
la séduction c'est ce côté culture de la
viralité c'est des masculinistes russes
qui trouvent que le viol c'est une
performance et cette culture c'est comme
ça qui met l'humour de son côté la
blague etc les moqueries par pénétrer
toute la société
on va regarder la juriste parce que
c'est comme ça qu'on arrive
tout ça ce sont les auteurs ce sont des
éléments ce qui a dit putin aussi
évidemment évidemment d'abord quand on
parle de justice on parle de tribunal
quand on parle de tribunal on parle de
qualification juridique pardon de
ramener bien pardon j'entends j'entends
ce qui est dit sur la définition de
génocide mais aujourd'hui on a des
définitions juridiques dans lesquelles
il faut rentrer et il faut lier des
éléments qui constituent un crime à un
auteur de crimes c'est ça la justice
pénale alors vous allez nous dire
comment mais déjà vous avez une
expérience sur cette question là des
crimes sexuels dans les conflits à quel
conflits ça vous fait penser par le
passé ce recours au viol aujourd'hui en
Ukraine mais il y en a plein en fait on
la pense à la Libye on pense à la série
c'est comparable mais déjà ce qui était
dit là moi j'ai beaucoup travaillé sur
le viol des hommes en Libye
l'utilisation du viol et des d'ailleurs
des tortures sexuelles de toute forme
c'est pour ça que crimes sexuelle
effectivement c'est très important c'est
utilisé on l'a vu dans les Balkans en
Bosnie-Herzégovine le viol a été un
outil de génocide au Rwanda donc il y a
plein de situations aujourd'hui on viole
dans énormément de pays dans le monde
nous mon ONG on travaille sur le monde
entier on a une carte je vous invite à
regarder la carte donc oui bien sûr
il faut trouver les moyens mais du coup
pour suivre mais simplement l'Ukraine on
est en plein conflit il y a un travail
de documentation qui est fait on voit
qu'il y a une forme de systématisation
parce que c'est ça c'est pas qu'une
question des ordres on a l'impression on
cherche l'ordre c'est à dire on cherche
celui qui aura écrit sur un papier
allez-y violet mais comme ce qui a été
dit juste avant c'est ce qu'on regarde
c'est est-ce que ces systématisé est-ce
que c'est répété est-ce que en gros à
chaque fois que les soldats russes
arrivent quelque part il y a des viols
je pense que ça c'est assez établi mais
ça reste à
affirmer quoi et c'est ça qu'il faut et
aussi le fait que au niveau des unités
au dessus dans la hiérarchie on laisse
faire si vous voulez c'est faire ça
c'est constitutif bien sûr vous pouvez
être poursuivi pour viol comme élément
constitutif de crime contre l'humanité
Mariana alors parce que on va sur le
terrain de de parallèle et à la fois de
la tradition de l'armée russe alors déjà
la
cette sortie de Vladimir Poutine avec ce
refrain de chansons et elle est déjà
très réminissante d'une chanson qui
avait été écrite pendant l'invasion de
la Finlande en 39 dont le refrain était
prendre nous sans la beauté donc on
traite Finlande comme une femme à violer
une femme belle donc moi le soldat russe
prends-moi c'est pour dire que en
réalité le viol est une
caractéristiques une longue tradition au
sein de l'armée russe et non pas depuis
10 ans mais depuis des décennies on
rappelle par ailleurs tous les viols qui
ont été commis par l'armée soviétique
en Allemagne nazie on se rappelle que le
prétexte de l'invasion de l'Ukraine
c'était la prétendue des nazification
une sorte de réactivation de ce mode
opératoire avec le mot génocide a même
été employé par poutine au début au
centre
tous les crimes de guerre y compris les
crimes sexuelles qui ont été commis par
l'armée russe a commencé par la première
guerre de Tchétchénie ou quasiment toute
la population homme femme enfant tous
les captifs étaient systématiquement
violés et on n'a jamais payé assez
attention à ce qu'il y a beaucoup de
choses dans tout ce que vous nous dites
et notamment sur cette culture du viol
en Russie maintenant comment on fait on
a l'impression Céline Bardet que il y a
déjà beaucoup beaucoup de d'enquête un
enchevêtrement de plein de strates
d'enquêteurs des ONG il y a la Cour
pénale internationale il y a des il y a
des juristes internationaux ça il faut
le faire il faut se coordonner mais il
faut déjà faire vite pour recueillir les
preuves parce que ça si elles peuvent
disparaître ça vous êtes d'accord
là-dessus oui au moins sur le recueil
des traces non non mais c'est important
de évidemment que c'est important de
faire vite bien sûr mais mais après sur
la singularité des crimes sexuels et
c'est ce que le documentaire je trouve
aussi montre excellentement bien c'est
que il y a un traumatisme il y a une
peur des représailles en l'occurrence en
Ukraine actuellement mais ça je vais
vous dire c'est partout moi je travaille
dans le monde entier j'entends aussi ce
que vous dites mais dans tous les
conflits dans le monde aujourd'hui on
utilise qu'on en fait trop sur l'Ukraine
non mais je veux dire on parle beaucoup
de l'Ukraine aujourd'hui et tant mieux
enfin je veux dire ce qui se passe
mérite qu'on en parle c'est pas la
question mais c'est de comprendre que le
viol est devenu un outil un mécanisme de
la guerre et du conflit et
qu'effectivement il faut qu'on arrive à
prendre conscience de ça quel tribunal
comment poursuivre est-ce il faut
laisser la justice ukrainienne est-ce
qu'il faut un tribunal spécifique est-ce
qu'il faut essayer de poursuivre un
maximum de chefs devant la Cour pénale
internationale il y a déjà beaucoup
beaucoup de d'ouverture de procédures en
fait là aujourd'hui il y a le parquet
ukrainien qui est compétent il y a la
Cour pénale internationale maman on
parle d'ouvrir un parquet européen pour
travailler au crime de d'agression qui
est autre chose et qui d'ailleurs va
concerner beaucoup plus Poutine et Léo
gradés je pense que le parquet ukrainien
peut très bien faire son travail après
la question elle va être ailleurs la
question elle va pas tant être de
documenter les éléments de preuve alors
c'est qu'on en a plein et les crimes
sont absolument multiples et horribles
la question ça va être l'analyse on
oublie souvent ça qui est triste
criminel internationale il y a l'étape
d'analyse aujourd'hui on a énormément
d'éléments ça prend du temps d'analyser
tout ça de faire le lien dont je vous ai
parlé encore une fois la justice c'est
pour suivre un individu donc il faut
lier cet individu à ce crime et donc
voilà donc il faudra déterminer la
qualification aussi il faut qualifier il
faut donc tout ça c'est un énorme de
guerre
génocide et l'agression comme la Cour
pénale internationale n'est pas
compétente pour l'Ukraine sur le crime
d'agression on a cette discussion de
créer un tribunal spécial je pense que
la volonté aussi de l'Ukraine en fait
dans le fond et qui est un tribunal
spécial comme il y a eu pour le l'axe
Yougoslavie ou le Rwanda ce qui
permettrait peut-être je pense d'être
une solution parce que la Cour pénale
internationale il y a plus de 60 je
crois qu'aujourd'hui on en a 70 000
dossiers ouverts au parc ukrainien 75000
comment voulez-vous mais que n'importe
qui n'importe quel pays dans le monde
puisse travailler sur 70 000 ou 75000
dossiers c'est pas possible donc il faut
donc il faut des renforts il faut des
renforts juridictionnels avec des
tribunaux spéciaux et les aider et il
faut aussi par juste réfléchir aussi à
d'autres formes de justice à un moment
si on a des masses de crimes il y a
d'autres matières aussi de rendre de
justice il y a des commissions
ce qu'on appelle la justice
transitionnelle il y a des toutes les
victime n'attendent pas que les auteurs
de crimes en prison c'était intéressant
ce qui est dit dans le documentaire
cette femme qui dit moi je parle parce
que je veux pas que ça arrive aux autres
et moi j'ai beaucoup de victimes dans le
monde aussi qui me disent parce qu'elles
y croient pas là elle ne croit pas
surtout que voilà on va pas cette
volonté les auteurs des fesses soient
poursuivies d'ailleurs la plupart des
procès aujourd'hui se font parcours
humains avec quelques bruits parce que
l'Ukraine le permet mais le les
procureurs enfin laissent la politique
en ce moment c'est de dire on laissera
le choix à la victime est-ce qu'elle
veut un procès en Ukraine là maintenant
ou pas en fait parce qu'il ne toutes les
victimes n'ont pas envie forcément d'un
procès donc ça vous l'avez vraiment
ressenti les victimes avant tout elles
veulent parler pour que ça n'arrive plus
presque davantage que pour recevoir
la justice un procès c'est ça
complètement et puis surtout on parle de
75 000 crimes de guerre mais en fait les
crimes de guerre à caractère sexuel
quand on regarde dans l'histoire de la
justice internationale ce sont souvent
pas cela qui sont jugés en priorité et
donc du coup les victimes elles ne sont
pas naïves sur le cours que va prendre
la justice et nationale et
internationale donc alors vous aurez le
mot de la fin Véronique disons que même
pour les viols en temps de paix la
justice les procès ont une difficulté
parce que cette question d'épreuve cette
question du témoignage de la honte qui
pèse sur les victimes donc en temps de
guerre pour démontrer une chaîne de
commandement pour des pratiques qui sont
tacites qui sont en dehors du langage et
des écrits à mon avis excusez moi j'aime
mon avis ça ça va être très très
difficile donc on peut comprendre que du
côté des victimes qui rêvent de justice
y est cette idée que témoigner faire des
films en attendant que le boulot de la
justice soit fait c'est déjà un premier
pas
énorme les choses soient dites dans le
travail de
qui reconstruction de soi de réparation
ce qui est intéressant dans le fait de
faire ses enquêtes alors que le conflit
continue c'est qu'il y a quand même
toute une question sur la récolte des
preuves on parle vraiment des crimes à
caractère sexuels parce que en fait les
femmes on va voir plus vite s'il y a eu
violent et puis il va y avoir tous
travaillent en open source avec les
téléphones les réseaux sociaux et que ça
a beaucoup changé les choses le
numérique ça change beaucoup les choses
aussi vous aurez le mot de la fin cette
fois-ci c'est sûr c'est important mais
la question que les gens se posent aussi
c'est est-ce qu'un jour Poutine pour
être traduit devant un tribunal pénal
international on peut aussi s'il y a un
changement en tout cas il peut y arriver
d'accusation donc s'il y a un changement
politique il peut se retrouver devant un
tribunal mais aussi vite s'y retrouver
devant un tribunal mais la chose que je
voulais dire c'est que ce qui est très
important aussi c'est en fait d'être à
l'écoute de ces personnes là de ces
victimes de ce qu'elles veulent et de
ceux dont elles ont besoin et du temps
aussi dont elles ont besoin parce que
c'est ça l'hortense c'est pas le même et
les crimes sexuels c'est très difficile
elles ont besoin de temps il y a des
victimes qui peuvent avoir été viol
aujourd'hui et qui parleront bien plus
longtemps après et votre film leur donne
ce temps et cet espace de reconnaissance
merci beaucoup merci d'être venu
débattre autour de votre documentaire il
en échoue c'est Marine Courtade merci à
vous c'est la fin de cette soirée
événement autour de la première année de
conflit en Ukraine bonsoir à tous